après avoir libéré l'oiseau bleu de
Twitter Elon Musk va-t-il enchaîner les
utilisateurs du réseau pour rentabiliser
son achat de 44 milliards de dollars
d'un éventuel modèle basé sur des
abonnements en allant même jusqu'à ce
que prononcer sur un montant d'une
vingtaine de dollars par mois pour
certains utilisateurs vérifiés il a
également sondé ses abonnés sur le
retour d'anciennes fonctionnalités comme
vine ou même la création de nouvelles
autant de ballons décès
et bon vous voyez aussi qu'il a été très
actif sur le plan de la gouvernance
puisque non seulement il a remercié
certains cadres supérieurs clés mais il
a aussi choisi de se séparer du conseil
d'administration actuelle il devient
donc le seul administrateur de son
entreprise et annonce dès son
acquisition la création d'un de
modération de contenu il affirme du même
élan que toutes les opinions pourront
s'exprimer la vision de la liberté
d'expression de Monsieur mosque est très
libertarienne et donc monsieur mask par
exemple c'est déjà prononcé contre le
bannissement à vie de sa plateforme
la porte du réseau est désormais ouverte
à des personnes aux propos très
polarisants la ligantid diffamation un
organisme américain a noté une
recrudescence des messages haineux sur
Twitter c'est un peu dommage parce que
les utilisateurs qui souhaiteront avoir
de la popularité pour de la popularité
ou qui auront des propos qui seront
disons très tranchées
auront peut-être tendance à utiliser cet
outil là mais malheureusement ce que ça
fait c'est que ça va rendre
l'aspect grand public de la chose
beaucoup moins intéressante pour
l'instant la vision d'ilon Mosk pour son
nouveau réseau ne se précise pas
beaucoup de questions demeure tant
suspens ce réseau social va-t-il
basculer vers un réseau asocial la ligne
est bien mince ici Yasmine Hayat
Radio-Canada Montréal